Taylor Swift proves she still dominates  country music the country crooner turned  pop princess is still on top when it  comes to her Nashville roots not did one  thing right on Wednesday day one the  best song of the Year award at the CMAs  for better man a song she wrote for the  country group Little Big Town  [Music]  [Applause]  the award was presented by Taylor's BFF  Carly cloths and the band accepted on  her behalf  Taylor wherever you are thank you for  this beautiful song though the 27 year  old singer wasn't in attendance she was  watching from New York City where she  revealed on Twitter she's rehearsing for  an upcoming SNL appearance Taylor's new  album reputation that drops Friday  November 10th what you do